I called Spotify the day after Rogan
signed and I said I would like 85
million dollars and they they were weird
about it but I said listen to me and
[ __ ] [ __ ] I also called Joe and I
said we honor you Joe I've been on the
show about three times I think I deserve
a little money here and I will have
lawyers tonight acting bright them and I
said I'll have lawyers because I think I
was on his podcast more than anybody
last nine times yeah and Brian goes
appear at the very least you could buy
us houses in Texas yeah yeah yeah the
deal you suck that's a good question we
could use a boat Joe the least you can
do by the way goes I've seen a dime from
the fight completely delusional
Psychopaths now think Spotify is giving
the money how great is that
how many mentally ill podcasters are
calling Spotify I'm calling their agent
be like hey you any money over there
like how about Spotify just like oh my
god we [ __ ] or we didn't emails and
calls non-stop people demanding millions
at all I just wanted 85 mil I said
listen that's a fair deal just by the
way Spotify buy me for two male 1 mil
they're worth five billion now yeah just
just underpaid our boy Rogen we think
about it care of the people who you need
to take care of that's all would you go
there where does YouTube hug for you
YouTube is screwed me up which is why if
you are watching this please subscribe
Tim Dylan show on YouTube only because
we were getting a hundred thousand plus
views on on a lot of our stuff then and
on the like algorithm whatever happened
you know my producer put a knife fight
in the title my fight in Malibu and I
guess maybe they're censoring it because
they think it's an actual knife fight
it's an expression I use it a realtor
said to me which I thought was hilarious
what the [ __ ] is some real I was talking
about renting a place in Malibu just
just seeing what how much it would cost
and you know one of these you like
grizzled old like malleable Realtors
gets on the phone she's like listen
she's the first of all she has no idea
who I am she's like listen Tim let me
tell you how it is it's a real knife
fight out here this markets and she's
like people are just they're just
swapping their egos their graven
properties left or right cuz I don't
care about coronavirus I don't care what
the government's and it's a real night
fighting here and I'm picturing a woman
who was now felt but not felt like her
husband's [ __ ] her assistant she's
just gritting her teeth she's driving
around and like a white poor so that's a
knife
smoking a cigarette smoke yeah just
totally knife fire just breaking in a
house like it's you know what I mean
it's just just closing deals that's the
only one hasn't goes dealing yeah it's
the only thing nice yeah
Boyce you just close these deals that's
the only way she can feel I like so fun
it's fun man it shows arcs I would build
in like everybody's face yeah I mean I
would I know
consonant I chose it even if I get it
I'll be fine look at the odds but yeah
this is the pool party from this past
weekend I'm all about it I'm here for it
you start living your life over
everyone's [ __ ] on the party like
everyone on Twitter is that go that
sorta hooks are house shut up what do
you think your party's fun in Echo Park
where you sit there and you talk about
all the sins America's committed shut
the [ __ ] up
I just can't that spawn there's booze
yeah water and the water you're pissing
in the water who cares
everyone's [ __ ] in the water nothing
better I just can't believe somebody to
post this much can you believe these
people it has nothing to do with you
it's nothing to do you demand father's
not directly affecting you you don't
want to go to the beach and stay off the
[ __ ] beach yeah who cares don't be a
rat don't be a rat I hate that dude I
hate how quickly people became rats like
two weeks in people like are those 16
year old skateboarding it's like stay
out of it to cost you six 9 made it cool
to be around
that's it think of it Hilary Duff don't
be a rat let her run a human trafficking
ring
stop being a rat all the design right
she's got to make money she's getting
older as a woman in Hollywood what you
got to do
you're right that looks so fun I can't
wait for those days I'm Way back in my
days I mean right now this is a eight
year old and I don't know you guys tell
me if this looks real to you or not but
this is him like these days I believe
that yeah why not that's just seems
impossible else is he gonna do I don't
know who was it Khloe Kardashian is that
what Khloe looks like that Roger - you
know is that right there now it's like
we can't even be shocked if Rob
Kardashian's it's a small Asian over you
small
on my radar if that was Rob Kardashian
thrice pazzo pazzo Larry yeah that's
crazy good for him I'll buy socks what
else you got stuff sold the real Khloe
Kardashian for experiments and then they
put in this new one my [ __ ] parents
how about my dad 80 we haven't talked
yeah so so I gotta see my father for his
80th birthday we shoot a round of golf
he couldn't be killing it more he's just
doing great but the [ __ ] guy kept
coming close to me and I go hey you
gotta I got tested and I'm negative
I got a swab actually got you know not
where they go in your brain yeah but
actually now they can do it on surface
so I came back negative
my sister came back negative but my dad
and my mom are like coming over and
they're like like three inches away
it was then I kept going hey I just
plain and also outright sit still you
days nothing well it takes two days
right to get the thing so home you know
just in case
but he's 80 and he's in a high altitude
and and if he gets it he could be in
[ __ ] real trouble Big Mike's yeah
they're both 80 you know yeah yeah and
and he's got he's got a heart he's got a
tribute fibrillation or some [ __ ] and
one it would be bad and he's [ __ ]
overweight so um but the [ __ ]
goes I go dude I go hey back off and he
goes like this he goes oh yeah I forgot
you're one of those I love it oh my come
on dude I love it anyway meanwhile
though he spends all his time outside
playing golf he's he kind of meaty
environment that's it that's it and and
they just stood my mother back you know
like seven bananas they had a party I
was the youngest person there I stayed
the [ __ ] away from everybody but I
didn't date he does away from me they
were all like you were scared I was
scared they weren't and you know what
they said a lot of more like you know
what I'm 80 I don't have time to be this
cautious I got a little my life and
there's no there are no cases up there
been a good run there are no cases are
there but I didn't want to be the one to
bring it there and kill the whole
[ __ ] party all right you know I was
thinking about that but they weren't
they weren't careful it was just so
funny man yeah it was it was wild is
your fun yes it was [ __ ] great it was
great to see a man at 80 and people were
making speeches about him and like his
life arose to them in his way they
wonder you know roast him there was just
like you know you you you've expanded my
life you've been so generous you neither
roared they use for my dad the mo
was generous that's good that's [ __ ]
cool when you're 80 I mean while the guy
hasn't lost a [ __ ] ounce of his wits
is he's still losing it what the dude oh
I forget about about the greatest
service talking about China and how
they're taking over and everything else
my father's listening who's spent his
whole life in international banking and
in China any sinner like this and he's
like and my sisters like another thing
about China and how they're taken over
and everything else
my father quietly goes I don't subscribe
to that point of view but he does it's
mine oh no that's my cue to go you don't
miss me I hate it I mean I know this is
the popular thing that you see it I knew
doesn't have to make money and and then
I go well what do you mean you don't
think Chinese are threatening us no I
don't I don't they innovate exactly
nothing let's just start with that
second of all the idea that they are
have influence in the world do you have
any idea and he went through what
they're facing economically what
problems they have economically and how
they failed over and over again in
influencing the United Nations yes even
though they spend money it was just
interesting to you don't you forget that
he has their own problems you pop was
also bitter at Oakdale pop has been
around but pop has spent a lot of time
in those places here doug liman who
directed I think edge of tomorrow with
Tom Cruise admit even so apparently Tom
Cruise and him and Elon Musk are
partnering up to film something in outer
space a movie in outer space news Tom
Cruise something in outer space like
he's just floating in the soul you see
the suit I've seen the new astronaut
suits nowhere near as cool back then
back in the day we're back and a they
were like marshmallow men have the cool
mass what are they no the new SpaceX
ones is just I think the Sun I think
Kanye might have designed them I don't
know but they look [ __ ] shitty oh like
that yes we're gonna close it look like
a Halloween costume
yeah that's not just not yes they seem
too accessible or two attainable like I
think they already universe and get this
you have to be to be an Oscar on there
like you have to like it's really hard
to be an Astra I'm sure those suits are
way more functional than the ones we're
used to they're come
to me this is like a Coachella or
something about space travel
really will you go to Mars if you had
the chance
no I would like a one-way ticket to Mars
no [ __ ] now aren't they they're selling
tickets though right to get to Mars
you'd have to have a gone with me so I
could stick it in my mouth
whoa oh that just that hope they're
trying to shoot a film in they're
actually planning on filming in outer
space I think they even mentioned the
space station or something some reason
like that idea because yes you have to
mimic like how good gravity did it with
[ __ ] George Clooney in yeah girl and
what so real yeah and you're gonna try
it I'm not gonna go oh my god they shot
that in outer space so gravity looks so
legit you know Tom Cruise is pretty like
hardcore what they've always does yeah
all that stuff so it seems like
something he would actually do but then
you just relax I'm saying shoot like
stunts aren't as dangerous on set
anymore like being an extra as the most
dangerous so he's gonna do all his own
extra work he's crazy
all right Doug Liman the Jake crazy the
guy looks so crazy 30 times while
talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift it's a gift